about 1730 staff sergeant Darren Hoover
friend and mentor
[Music]
came to get me from the tower to go help
find an Afghan interpreter in the crowd
we found the interpreter and his brother
born with American passports they told
us five told us of five family members
still in the canal
I stayed there waiting for the family
members standing against a two foot
Canal wall ten minutes passed
then a Flash and a massive wave of
pressure
I'm throwing 12 feet onto the ground but
instantly knew what had happened I
opened my eyes to Marines dead or
unconscious lying around me
foreign
a crowd of hundreds immediately vanished
in front of me and my body was
catastrophically wounded with 100 to 150
ball bearings now in it
almost immediately we started taking
fire from the neighborhood and I saw how
injured I was with my right arm
completely shredded and unusable
I saw my lower abdomen soaked in blood
I crawled backwards seven feet roughly
seven feet because I thought I was still
In Harm's Way
my body was overwhelmed from the trauma
of the blast my abdomen had been ripped
open every inch of my exposed body
except for my face took ball bearings
and shrapnel
I tried to get up but could not
laying there for a few minutes I started
to lose consciousness
when I heard Chaz my team leader
screaming my name as he ran to me
his voice
his voice calling to me kept me awake
when he got to me he dragged me to
safety and immediately started triaging
me tying tourniquets on my limbs and
doing anything he could to stop the
bleeding and start plucking wounds with
the help of the other Marines
I was awake through most of it screaming
moaning and cursing please ask I ask you
to please ask me about getting shot at
the tower in Abby gate and how no one
wanted my report post blast
even NCIS and the FBI failed to
interview me asked me to elaborate on my
ordeal post blast and asked me about
this one little girl in her family that
I reunited
our military members and Veterans
deserve our best because that is what we
give to America
the withdrawal
the withdrawal was a catastrophe in my
opinion
and there was an inexcusable lack of
accountability and negligence
the 11 Marines one sailor
and one soldier that were murdered that
day have not been answered for
thank you for giving me this opportunity
to speak